اخبار الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه بايجاز
من رام الله مرحبا بكم في اليوم الثال
والعشر من حرب اسرائيل على غزه اكثر من
8000 شهيد ونحو 20 الف جريح وسط استمرار
غارات الاحتلال المكثفه على القطاع في حين
تقول كتائب القسام انها قصفت عددا من
المدن الاسرائيليه وباغت القوات
الاسرائيليه المتو شمال غرب بيت لاهيه بعد
التسلل خلف خطوطها والجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد
اصابه ضابط بجروح خطره وجندي بجروح
متوسطه انسانيا وزاره الصحه في غزه تعلن
استشهاد اكثر من 100 من الكوادر الطبيه
وتدمير 25 سياره اسعاف واستهداف اكثر من
50 مؤسسه صحيه وتقول ان عوده الانترنت
كشفت حجم ما وصفتها بالمحرك الاسرائيليه
وتؤكد انه لم يطرا اي جديد في ملف
المساعدات الطبيه للمستشفيات وتحذر من
انتشار متسارع للاوبئه بين النازحين بسبب
شح المياه وقله النظافه
الشخصيه وفي تل ابيب وقفه احتجاجيه تطالب
باعاده الرهائن بغض النظر عن المقابل
ونتنياهو يحذف تغريده حمل فيها رئيسي
الشباك والاستخبارات العسكريه مسؤوليه
هجوم حماس في السابع من اكتوبر بعد تعرضه
لهجوم واسع من قيادات المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ويعلن اعتذاره بشان انتقاده
لقاده الاجهزه الامنيه ويعترف بانه كان
مخطئا وعلى صعيد تصريحات وردد الفعل
المتحدث باسم الداخليه في غزه يطالب
بتقديم قاده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى
محاكم جرائم الحرب ويدعو مصر الى اتخاذ
قرار تاريخي بوقف الكارثه ويشدد على انها
قادره على ذلك ووزير الخارجيه الكويتي
يقول ان حرب اسرائيل على غزه هي حرب
انتقاميه اما الرئيس الايراني فقال
للجزيره ان امريكا هي السبب وراء عرقله
مساعي وقف اطلاق النار وادخال المساعدات
للقطاع الى
اللقاء
ه